The overall revenue
management problem
involves a network of airports
and literally thousands
of flights.
Clearly optimization is needed.
Myopic solutions leave
significant revenue
on the table.
Furthermore, revenue
management involves
tens of different classes that
have different restrictions,
different characteristics
like mile awards, and fares.
PEOPLExpress could not compete
with American Airlines'
Ultimate Super Saver fares.
Donald Burr, CEO of
PEOPLExpress in 1985,
notes, "We were a vibrant,
profitable company
from 1981 to 1985, and
then we tipped right over
into losing $50 million a month.
We had been profitable
from the day
we started until American
came at us with Ultimate Super
Savers."
Revenue management
is the science
of selling the right seats
to the right customers
at the right prices.
To illustrate the impact
that revenue management has
had on American
Airlines, we note
what Robert Crandall,
CEO of American,
wrote during the period
that revenue management
practices were applied.
"Revenue management is
the single most important
technical development in
transportation management
since we entered the era
of airline deregulation.
We estimate that
revenue management
has generated $1.4 billion
in incremental revenue
in the last three years."
Let us see the impact of
revenue management more broadly.
Today, American Airlines
has emerged from bankruptcy
by merging with US Air Airlines.
However, American
Airlines has spun
off Sabre Holdings,
the entity that
built revenue
management for American.
As of November 2012,
Sabre ranked 133rd
among America's largest private
companies with $3.15 billion
in sales, 400 airlines, 90,000
hotels, and 30 car rental
companies as clients.
Today, companies prosper
from revenue management.
Delta Airlines, for example,
increased annual revenue
by $300 million.
Marriott hotels increased
annual revenue by $100 million.